عروسه الاسماعيليه مها محمد اللي شغاله
الراي العام العربي والمصري بسبب تعنيف
زوجها لها الناس متابعه التطورات قصتها من
البدايه وتحديدا من بعد ما انتشر مقطع
فيديو لها وهي بتتعرض للضرب من زوجها في
الشارع يوم الفرح ومن بعدها طلعت هي
وزوجها وقالوا انه اللي صار سوء تفاهم
بينهم وانتهت القصه بعد ثمانيه اشهر
اتفاجا الناس بفيديو لها وهي بتستغيث
بالشرطه وبتقول انه ضربها واحتجازها 15
يوم في منزل اخوه ورفعت عليه قضيه وبدات
جلسات المحاكمه اليوم انتهت الجلسه
الثالثه والاخيره للمحاكمه والمحكمه قضت
على عريس الاسماعيليه عبد الله محمود
بالسجن لمده سنه مع الشغل والنفاذ وتعويض
قدره 2000 جنيه لزوجته مها محمد
المنتخب سنه
المصاريف المدنيه ثانيا ببراءه المتهم من
تهمه احتجاز المدعيه بالحق المدني مها
محمد عمران محمد اتهام الاول رفعت الجلسه
طيب وتنضم الينا من القاهره فريده
الشوباشي عضو البرلمان المصري اهلا فيك
معانا من اول شيء طبعا اكيد حضرتك تتابعتي
القصه ايش رايك في العقوبه انه سنه مع
الشغل والنفاذ و 2000 جينات تعويض
يعني انا طبعا بعتبر ان الامر امام القضاء
بيبقى في كل التفاصيل احنا ما عندناش كل
التفاصيل
ومجرد الاذان هنا والحبس فهذا اول مره
يحصل نوع من الردع للرجال اللي بيعتدوا
على زوجاتهم بالضرب يعني انا مش فاهمه زي
ممكن واحد يتصور ان انسانه تعيش معه بعد
ما يهينها بانه يضربها لان الضرب ده اخر
حاجه يعني اخر حاجه الواحد بيلجا لها ولو
ما قدرش يوصل لها لا هو مش اخر حاجه هو ما
المفروض يعني يوصل لها اصلا
خلينا نكون متفقين يعني طبعا ما انا باقول
اخر ولا يوصلك اخر حاجه يوصل لها
لو ضربها بقى يبقى ما فيش حياه مشتركه بعد
كده اوكي ده اللي انا بقوله يعني يعني لو
واحد يتصور ان بعد ما يضرب مراته هترجع له
كمان وتبقى عاديه معه يبقى عنده اختلال
ولكن هذا اللي حصل هذا اللي حصل هو ضربها
ويوم الفرح ومقطع موثق وما الى ذلك ويرجعك
وبعدين قال لما تركها صارت الناس تقول انه
اللي يضرب مره يضرب اكثر من مره وما له
ذلك يعني همم كان في تناقضات كثير في هذه
القصه
بالضبط كده هو استغل هذه الترددات وانا
طبعا الوم عليها برده انا لو يوم الفرح
ضربها كان حقها سابتهم الفرح يعني وكنت
بقت الفرحه انها اكتشفت هو ايه بالضبط
انا ما بقدرش اتصور ان واحده تعيش مع واحد
ضربها
يعني ازاي يعني ازاي بعد كده يدومهم فراش
واحد ويضموه منزل واحد ودموهم اا مصير
مشترك واولاد مشتركه لا ما ينفعش يعني
يعني
على فكره عجز كمان ايوه وحضرتك يعني نمتي
عليه هو ولومتي عليها هو هي هي قبلت بس
كمان كان في منظومه سواء مثلا من الاهل او
حتى شفنا بعض الناس على التلفزيون طلعوا
تكلموا وقالوا يا جماعه هدوا النفوس خلوهم
يعني انه نوفق بينهم والطلاق ده امر مش
كويس فالموضوع يعني اجتماعي افضل
شوفي هي قالت لنا دلوقت بعد الفتاوي بتاعه
بعض الشيوخ او يعني المدعي ان هم شيوخ
اللي بيتكلموا عن ضرب المراه على فكره
ربنا كرم المراه ربنا كرم المراه تكريم لا
مثيل له ولا حاجه تعلو الى مستواه يعني
انه اودع فيه الرحم او ده فيها الرحم هل
ستتوها بالحياه يعني ما فيش عظيم في
العالم ممكن ان يكون له وجود لو لم تلدهم
امراه اظن دي ما فيهاش مناقشه
يعني الانبياء والرسل والزعماء وكله
المراه هي اللي ولدتهم فربنا كرمها انت
تيجي تضربها عشان ما اتفقتش معك في حاجه
يعني ما اتصلتش الاوامر سيادتك يعني ازاي
يعني انا ضد حكايه الضرب دي خالص يعني طيب
قانونيا ايه رايي ان اقنعني بس انه
قانونيا هل نحن بنتكلم انه بشكل عام في
عقوبات رادعه ولا حضرتك تشعري انه لابد من
مثلا فرض المزيد من العقوبات على هذا
الموضوع موضوع تعني في المراه
لا انا انا رايي انه يعني نوع العقوبه
بيقدروا القاضي واحنا قضائنا قضاء محترم
يعني
التشريعات بقى يعني انا في مجلس النواب
اعتقد انه هيبقى في مطالبه بتشريعات قويه
او اقوى من كده علشان يبقى نوع من الردع
مش معقول الفوضى اللي بقينا فيها ان كل
واحد مش- شوفي
الجدع اللي قتل واحده عشان ما رضيتش
تتجوزه مثلا هو في ايه يعني
هذا مش شخص واحد هذه اصبحت ظاهر الحقيقه
بالضبط
تحقير المراه
والتقليل من شانها والتقليل من مكانتها
يعني هو ده هي دي الحاجه الكارثيه اللي
انا عايشها دلوقت لان انا كبيره قوي في
السن واا كنت عشت قبل كده قبل فتره
السبعينات
ال- ال- الخطاب ال- اللجان من بعض الناس
همم وما فيش كلام دلوقتي خالص اللي عن
المراه والرجل والعلاقه الحميميه ما فيش
احد بيتكلم عن ان ربنا قال قل اعماله
فسيرى الله عملكم ورسوله والمؤمنون ما فيش
احد قال ان ربنا قال من شاء فليؤمن ومن
شاء فليكفر ما حدش بيقول ان ربنا قال لا
اكرهها في الدين كل حاجه بقى في ناس
بتعتبر نفسها بتنصب نفسها قال لها همم
فيعني الالهه دي يعني لازم المراه ترجع
قدامه ده ده تماما يعني استاذه فريده يمكن
انت اول واحده اعرفها هتقول انا كبيره قوي
في السن
ههه معلش ما انا كبيره اعمل ايه انا على
فكره بحب الصراحه
العمر كله ان شاء الله يا رب
بس يعني حضرتك
متقوليش لحد حاضر انا ماشيه في ال 85 ما
شاء الله الله اكبر
لما كنت في باريس اخر مره قبل الكرونه
فديت للراجل بتاع
المطار بتاع شرن
الباسبور بتاعي فبصلي وضحك ليه في حاجه
تضحك يعني قال لي لا اصلك ما تعمليش سنك
ما تديش سنك يعني فانا كانوع من البيت
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
ان شاء الله بصحه وعافيه كانت معنا فريده
عضو البرلمان المصري شكرا لك شكرا